[Applause]
before the break we were talking about
your job your job your real job as a
lifeguard but you were also a sous chef
as well do you still love to cook I love
cooking yes how did
counting to that idea that theme that
you like cooking yeah I just really want
to like it and I go in there and there's
like two things I make that I'm like
cool but like I just really want to be
into it what got you into it I think
well my family all cooked together when
I was oh well and my dad did a lot of
cooking and my mom did too my dad did
the mostly the like warm food cooking
and my mom did the cold food cooking
like she would make a killer salad and
then my dad would make like the you know
protein or whatever you know yeah and so
but we always got like best a long best
at the at the table you know it was like
the conversations we'd have and the food
we all love food so I started to just
love it I don't really know where it
came from I just love eating so then I
was like well I'm into that part yeah so
just I can't yeah I try I'm trying and
we do so many cooking things on the show
yeah and I'm trying to get into it but
every time I get in there I'm like or I
could read you don't have to this is the
thing yeah I think that there's a lot of
pressure on that line yeah I mean I do
think there's a lot of pressure on
needing to be able to cook somehow and I
don't know what it is and I you gotta
love it like you just I feel like are
you healthier though because because
that's why I feel like people
are generally really healthy yeah um
like a shiny example of that so like I I
think that's not healthy no I eat really
good things but I also really love bad
things yeah but you can you can cook bad
things and like with good ingredients
well if you love something you can be
like I love this thing and then I'm
gonna find the ingredient it doesn't
have to be really good ingredients you
just start cooking it and then you're
like oh I'm gonna try it this way and
try it that way and then you just do it
differently and then it changes stuff
you know I have tried several times with
healthy ingredients and sometimes I'm
like no no yeah it's funny you say that
because I just I tried to bake this
thing the other day that's in this
amazing I love baking yeah I do love
baking not cooking well it's sort of
different I mean it's sort of different
I'm not going to argue with you there
that's right I feel like that's a very
it takes no spot it's just like it's not
true no I feel like it's all the Bakers
in the world just went like it takes no
thought no it takes like
you're in a fake child yeah you fake
Baker I feel like because of cooking
they're like a dab a splash of you know
pinch and I'm like that's relative oh I
mean and you need actually I need it I
need the chemistry like
all the scientists hate you too no I
just mean I need the I need the recipe
and I can follow it to tea and I'm good
at baking yeah I mean I I understand I
think big is really hard I think it's
hard to think oh I love baking well yeah
we go good at that okay what did you
bake though I I baked this like uh like
um flourless chocolate meringue cake oh
I love my from this amazing book by this
woman rain is hard yeah oh shut up
no mine is so hard for me I mean I screw
it up how do you do it not well do you
to use an electric mixer do you use like
a whisk I I've done both I've done both
I've lost a competition to my tour
manager once on a pie because of the
meringue it was a sad meringue really
yeah what did you do though did you use
like a healthy ingredient it didn't work
out well yeah I tried it that's what I
tried coconut sugar which is just a no
not real no-go for for an egg white I do
just need regular sometimes you just
need the bad stuff you just need regular
sugar it's like monk fruits wonderful I
love monk fruits yeah you need you need
to go for you know real sugar it really
makes those those stiff peaks you know
yes and that's what you need for a
meringue you know what I mean I use real
sugar I just sucked at it um
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going
[Music]